字幕: Madhuri Mohanagopal
校正: Hiroe Nakada
僕は 自分の辛い経験を
自分らしい輝きに繋げる人を増やしていきたい
そのためにひとつ
どうしても変えなければならないものがあります
ここにいるみなさんと一緒に
今日この場所で変えたいんです
その前に少し質問があります
あなたは今まで学校に通っていましたか
「通っていたよ」という方は
手を挙げてください
多いですね ありがとうございます
では もうひとつ質問です
あなたは今まで
「なんか今日学校いやだな」
「今日学校休んじゃおうかな」
そう思ったことはありますか
あるという方は手を挙げてください
ありがとうございます 嬉しい反応で
では 最後の質問です
ある言葉に対して あなたが
どの様なイメージを持っているのかを
お聞きします
その言葉は 学校に通っていたあなたに
「今日いやだな」と思ったことがある
あなたに関わる言葉です
その言葉はこちら
不登校
この言葉を見て
あなたは何を感じるでしょうか
「いやあなんかネガティブだな」
「あんまよくないな」
そう思う人は手を挙げてください
８割 ９割ぐらいですかね
ありがとうございます
僕はこれを変えたいんです
僕は社会が持つ あなたが持つ
その不登校に対するイメージを
変えていきたいんです
ではなぜ それを変える必要があるのか？
それは 不登校という一見辛い経験が
実は辛いだけのものではない
という気付きこそが
自分の辛い経験を自分らしい輝きにつなげる上で重要になるからです
つい先日 辛い経験を
辛いだけのものとして考えたことで
起きてしまった事件がありました
ある家族のおばあちゃんが
自分の孫が15歳で不登校であることで
孫の将来を悲観して 孫が寝ている間に
首を絞めて 金槌で殴ったんです
不登校になると 将来の可能性が
制限されてしまうのではないか
そんなネガティブなイメージが原因で
辛い経験を辛いだけのものとして考えて
尊い命すらも失われようとしてしまったんです
今不登校生は全国に約18万人います
苦しんでいるのは不登校生だけでなくて
そのお父さん お母さん
おじいちゃん おばあちゃん 兄弟
その家族が苦しんでいるんです
数字をみると 学校の環境の変化が特に大きい
中学生が数も多いことがわかります
これを割合にすると クラスに約１人
なので 皆さんの中にも
自分の知り合いが不登校だったという方も
いらっしゃるのではないでしょうか
そしてこの中学校における
クラスの不登校生の割合が
２年連続で全国で一番多い都道府県があるんです
それは
宮城県
宮城県は全国の中でも
不登校問題が特に深刻な所なのです
だから僕は今この場所に立っています
これだけ苦しんでいるこの宮城県から
不登校が持つ力を
そして 辛い経験が実は
辛いだけのものではないということを
僕は日本に対して そして世界に対して
発信していきたいのです
では なぜ僕がそれをどうしても伝えたいのか
それは 僕自身が
実は不登校を経験していたからなのです
僕は中学校の頃 野球部に所属していました
顧問の体罰がとてもひどくて
毎日いやだなと思っていました
そしてある日 小さな誤解が積み重なって
理不尽に暴力を受けて
僕は反抗として１週間学校を休んでみたのです
学校を１日休む事はすごく簡単なのです
けれど学校を１週間休むと
「友達に何か悪口を
言われているんじゃないかな」とか
「もう僕の居場所がないんじゃないかな」と
思い悩んでしまうんです
そして僕は １週間学校を休んだつもりだったのに
「あと１日だけ休もう
もう１日だけ休もう」と思い続けて
１週間のつもりが、１ヶ月、半年、１年・・・
そして中学校２年生の終わりまで
約１年半学校に通うことができませんでした
その頃は毎日 インターネットゲームを
12時間 13時間ひたすらやっていました
話す相手はゲームの世界の人なんです
食生活も乱れて 昼夜逆転の生活で
自分の容姿もどんどんと乱れていきました
だから 外に出ることがとても怖いんです
周りで誰かが会話をしていると
「絶対に俺の悪口を言っているんだな」
「学校に通えてすらない俺なんて
そりゃみんなにも悪口を言われるよな」
そう思って すべてのことを
ネガティブに捉えてしまっていました
そんな僕の姿を見て
僕の両親や 先生 友達は僕の事を支えようと
たくさん声をかけてくれました
でもそれに対して僕は
「こっちに来んな！俺の事わかんねーだろ！」
沢山の人の支えを 否定してしまったのです
だから僕は変わらなければいけないと思いました
でもどうしても変わる事が出来ませんでした
僕のせいで沢山の人が苦しんでいるのです
「じゃあ僕が この世から
いなくなればいいんじゃないか」
僕はそう思って ある日
家にあった風邪薬の瓶を開けて
瓶ごと50粒ぐらい 出しては飲んで 出しては飲んで
何に使うのかよくわからない薬や液体も
片っ端からすべて飲み干したことがありました
命は助かりました
けれど ２日間吐き続ける状態で
寝ることもできない
不登校の頃は正直 苦しい経験もしました
でも不登校になったきっかけは
小さな誤解が積み重なって 理不尽に暴力受けて
反抗として１週間休んだことなんです
初め皆さんに質問した時に
「今日学校行きたくないな」と思ったことが
ある方はたくさんいらっしゃいましたよね
もし 数日間学校を休んでいたら
あなたも僕と同じ様に
不登校になっていた可能性が大いにあるんです
誰しもが不登校になり得るんです
今社会で働いている皆さん
息子さん娘さんはいらっしゃいますか？
今学生の皆さん
周りに学生の友達たくさんいますよね ？
将来子ども欲しいですよね？
そのあなたにとっての大切な人も
不登校になり得る可能性が大いにあるんです
でも 決してそこで嘆き悲しまないで欲しいんです
なぜなら 不登校は確かに辛い経験ではありますが
でも 不登校だからこその輝きもあるんです
じゃあ不登校の輝きって一体どんなものなのか
僕はそれを 高校２年生の時に経験しました
右に写っているのは 僕と同じ部活にいた
僕の大切な友人である ミノル
ミノルは僕たちハンドボール部の大エースとして
いつも活躍して
僕たちのことを常に支えてくれていました
ただ そのミノルが急に
学校に来れなくなったことがありました
クラスの友達が 部活のメンバーが
先生方がいくら彼に声をかけても
一向に学校に来てくれませんでした
「僕の大事な友人が
僕が苦しんだ不登校で苦しんでいる
それなら 僕の不登校という経験が
もしかしたらミノルの支えになるかもしれない」
僕はそう思って 初めて
僕の不登校の経験を打ち明けました
すると彼は 急に心を開いてくれて
また学校に通うようになってくれたんです
僕も友達も先生も
彼がまた学校に来てくれて本当に嬉しかった
そして一時期は
学校を辞めるとまで言っていた彼は
今は大学ではとあるプロジェクトを立ち上げて
自分で代表をやって
たくさんの仲間を支える存在にまで
なっているんです
ミノルは 僕にとって今でも 大事な友人なんです
けれど もし僕が４年前のあの時
不登校を経験していなくて
彼の事を理解することができなかったら
そして彼も自分の心を
打ち明ける相手がいなかったら
彼は学校を辞めて
もうこの様な関係はなかったかもしれません
まさに僕の不登校という経験が
同じ苦しみを抱える人の支えになったんです
不登校以外にもたくさんの苦しい経験が
あると思います
みなさんも何か辛い経験をしたことが
あるんじゃないでしょうか
そして振り返ってみると その辛い経験が
同じ辛さを抱える人の支えになったり
あれだけ辛かったからこそ
今辛い状況があっても
僕は 自分は 頑張れるんだと突き進む原動力に
なっていることもあると思います
でも 苦しい時に
それに気付くことって難しいですよね
だから僕は伝えたいんです
全国にいる約18万人の不登校生に
そしてその家族に
不登校は確かに辛い経験だけれども
辛いだけではないんだと
不登校には 不登校だからこその輝きがあるんだと
そして 不登校だからこその輝きを
放つ人達の姿を通じて
他にもたくさんある自分の辛い経験を
辛いだけのものとして捉えるのではなくて
自分らしい輝きに繋げる人を
増やしていきたいんです
僕はその想いを体現するために
この十人十輝（ジュウニントイロ）という
任意団体を立ち上げました
僕たち十人十輝は 自分たちが経験した
不登校やいじめ 家庭問題
そういったネガティブなものを自分達らしい
輝きに繋げようという想いで立ち上がりました
僕たちが目指しているのは 自分の辛い経験を
辛いものとして考えるのではなくて
自分らしい輝きに繋げる人を増やしていくこと
そこで鍵となるのが 不登校なんです
なんで不登校が鍵になるのか
いったいなぜなのか
初め皆さんに質問した時 不登校に対して
どんなイメージを持っていましたかね
多くの方がネガティブなイメージを
持っていましたよね
でもその一見ネガティブな不登校生が
可能性が制限されてしまうのではないかと
思われている不登校生が
自分と同じ苦しみを抱える人を支えていったり
自分の辛さを原動力に
前に突き進んでいく姿を見たら
あなたは何を感じますか
不登校という一見辛い経験が
実は辛いだけのものではなくて
実は不登校だからこその可能性があるんだと
その気付きがあなたにとって あなたの辛い経験も
実は自分らしい輝きに繋がるということに
気付くのではないでしょうか
まさに十人いれば 十通りの輝きがある
自分の苦しみを 自分らしい輝きに繋げる人を
増やしていきたいんです
そして この十ある輝きのうちのひとつが
不登校だと思っています
そこで僕たちは 不登校だからこその輝きを放つ
不登校生を増やしていくために
様々なきっかけを作っています
例えば フリーペーパー
『不登校だから世界が広がった』の制作
不登校になると 将来の可能性が
制限されてしまうのではないか
そんなことは絶対に無いんです
不登校になれば
不登校だからこその世界が広がるんです
それを伝えるためにこの雑誌を作っています
ここでの目玉コンテンツが 『進撃の不登校』
不登校生の中には その経験を糧に
前進していく 突き進んでいく
まさに進撃していく不登校生が
たくさんいるんです
僕たちはそういった
すごい不登校生のすごい可能性を
取材を通じて 雑誌を通じて
世の中に発信していきたい
例えば その不登校生の一人が
この同志社大学１年生の
塩澤明子（シオザワメイコ）さん
彼女は 小学校５年生から中学校３年生までの
約５年間の不登校経験を糧に
その当時の想いを綴った本を出版しました
そして不登校に悩む数多くの人から
５分おきに電話がかかってくるくらい
その経験を糧にたくさんの人を
支えていったんです
僕たちはこの様なすごい不登校生を
どんどんと生み出していきたい
そのために他にも元不登校生として
現役不登校生に寄り添って
もっと魅力的な大学を伝えていこうと
そんな想いで立ち上げた
この不登校オープンキャンパス
その他にも 教室にいなくても自宅であっても
病室であっても 保健室であっても
遠隔でリアルな授業を受けられる様に
ロボットを活用したプロジェクトを立ち上げたり
不登校に関心の無い人に 関心を持ってもらう
ための不登校ツアーを開催したり
たくさんのプロジェクトを立ち上げています
僕は初めあなたに不登校に対してどの様な
イメージを持っているのかをお聞きしました
もう一度振り返ってみてください
どんなイメージを持っていましたか
そのイメージは今 どう変わっていますか
少なくとも不登校がだたネガティブな
ただ辛いだけのものではないと
気付いた人が多いのではないでしょうか
同じ苦しみを抱える人を支えていったり
その辛さを原動力にする
不登校生がたくさんいるんです
そのあなたの中に起きている
不登校に対するイメージの変化こそが
僕が今日 あなたと一緒にこの場所で
起こしたかったことなんです
なぜなら この気付きこそが
自分自身の他にも様々ある辛い経験が
実は自分らしい輝きに繋がるということに
繋がっていくからです
僕は今日不登校を通してこの話をしました
それは僕自身が不登校を経験していたからです
でも不登校以外にも
辛い経験ってたくさんありますよね
では あなたはどの様な経験をしてきましたか
どんな経験をしたでしょうか
そしてその経験をいま どの様に捉えていますか
不登校は 一見ネガティブには見えたけど
実は辛いだけではなくて
何かチカラを持っていた
ではあなたのその経験はどうなんでしょうか
あなたのその経験も自分と同じ苦しみを
抱えている人の支えになったり
その辛さが自分が頑張る原動力になったり
その辛さこそがあなたのあなたらしい輝きに
繋がっていくんです
そして僕たちは まさに自分らしい
自分の輝きを放っていく
十人いれば十通りの輝きがある世界を
皆さんと一緒に作っていきたい
これから突き進んでいきたいと思っています
ありがとうございました